foreign
how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so Dave I have a question for you I am
debt free I listen to your books
followed the instructions and I have the
comment free that moves my cars to the
loans the whole shebang way to go kiddo
yes that took income ratio is zero I owe
nobody nothing but my dilemma is now I
feel like I probably missed the race of
me purchasing a home like I this would
be like my first time ever purchasing a
home and so my question to you Dave is I
know interest rates are up prices are
somewhat going down for a home should I
should I buy like what should I do
because I mean
I don't I don't know what I should do
right now
I want to buy a home I feel like I'm
ready to buy a home my credit score is 8
10. my debt to income ratio is zero and
why would you're not ready to purchase
because everybody is saying that the
interest rates are you know it's the
housing prices are too too high which
means my mortgage would be too much have
you noticed that everybody is stupid
fish
you notice that yeah yeah
everybody's in debt not rickette
very true do you have a down payment
saved up
I have about like
um what total am I saving to have like
50 000 like completely saved okay not
including That's not including
um my pension you know I work for the
um I work for the state a government job
so I've been here for like five years so
if you leave your emergency fund out of
that and you put the rest of it down and
you can do a 15-year fixed where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay then I wouldn't hesitate
to tell you to buy uh your Phoenix
Market had shot up and has adjusted down
it is one of the a handful of markets
that have adjusted down the rest of them
have just slowed their growth rate
that you're not going to see a market
like 2008 where Phoenix prices go down
substantially you're just not going to
see it there's too much demand
okay and if you buy with high interest
rates and interest rates go down what do
you do
you say ding ding you get the prize
and I think it's just important that you
still get a house that you can afford I
feel like a lot of people in this market
assume you know if they are going to go
in then they got to go push up their
monthly payment a little bit more or
something like that but still look at a
house that you know brings your monthly
payment to a quarter of your take-home
pay or below make sure you're still
reasonable and thoughtful as you go
through it because I think the fear can
do both things that can make you either
stay out of the market or go a little
crazy and try to justify some purchase
that you shouldn't make we've had
several people call in and say you know
we we got a house but you know the
Market's so crazy and we look at the
numbers and it's 40 of their take-home
pay don't do that like still be
reasonable still use wise decision
making in it but if you have you know no
debt if you have a down payment and
you're ready to buy and you find a house
you can afford then still go for it yeah
exactly I think it's a really good point
just because people in Washington are
stupid
just because they've gone crazy just
because inflation's going crazy doesn't
mean you need to go crazy
because guess what they're still going
to be crazy while you're being broke
because you did something stupid so
don't just go I won't I you know I don't
have to worry about math anymore because
there's inflation math doesn't count
this year we get a year off from math no
you get math in California in Manhattan
and in Nashville you get math everywhere
you go and math is going to kick your
butt when you buy something you can't
afford and you used all of your emotions
to justify Christine is exactly right